you might be familiar with the idea of
evolution that species change over time
and you can see that if you look at old
bones old fossils how they change
through the fossil record
but the obvious question is how do these
species actually do that what is the
mechanism well one of the major
mechanisms is natural selection
so natural selection is all based on at
any given point in time there is
variation in the species there are
different traits that are expressed in
different ways
and many times a lot of those variations
are fine but then you could have
environmental factors which make some of
those traits more favorable than others
and if those traits are more favorable
to be able to survive to be able to get
food or to be able to reproduce well
then the genes that code for those
traits are more likely to be passed on
generation after generation
and to make this very tangible i will
give you the example of the peppered
moth which is probably the most common
example when people show evidence of
natural selection
if you were to go to the mid-1800s in
london
most of the peppered moths were the
white peppered moths
there were very few black peppered moths
but there was variation there would be
some lighter ones there would be some
darker ones and in between
now what's interesting is between the
mid-1800s and the late 1800s you have
the industrial revolution in london
really hitting full gear and so there
was a lot of pollution in the air and so
a lot of the surfaces that the moths
might rest on like trees or the wall of
a building became darker and darker so
as where these moths could rest became
darker and darker what do you think
might have happened
well some of you might guess in this
different environment now as the
environment is gradually changed all of
a sudden having the traits that make you
darker will be more favorable than they
were even 30 or 40 or 50 years ago and
the white trait which might have been
okay in the mid-1800s now all of a
sudden makes these moths very
obvious to see
so if there was a bird that was looking
for lunch it'd be very easy to pick off
the white moths versus the black moths
and what we saw is actually by the 1900s
most of the peppered moths in london
were now darker in color and so what you
had happening generation after
generation is variation in the moth
color but as the background environment
became darker the ones that were white
colored were easier to pick off by
predators and if they're picked off by
predator they're definitely not
reproducing and passing on their genes
and then the ones that were able to
survive and pass on their genes were the
darker moths
now what's been interesting over the
last 50 or so years as environmental
regulations have gone into effect and
the air has started to clean up in
places like london you're seeing a
return of the white peppered moth
because once again the surfaces are no
longer covered with soot and so the
variants that are lighter in color now
have a decent chance of not being
spotted and if anything now the darker
ones might have a better chance of being
spotted in this cleaner environment